so with dark girls did you already have
distribution in place before you made
your investment there was not one piece
of distribution in place when we put our
money together to make dark girls we
were passionate about this topic because
both of us met my co partner Tim berry
we had are both dark-skinned black men
who have faced the prejudice of being
dark complected in her own community and
we saw members of our family little
girls from 5 6 7 8 9 10 years old going
through this pain being called monkey
ape gorilla face ugly and asking
their mothers can they be bleached
lighter because they were ugly and the
parents trying to say so he said no
let's see what happens so we made the
film when we cut a trailer the trailer
online and I got 2.3 million global hits
and we said we have something we have
something
so let's see if we can get a touring
company to he did we got a touring
company tourists around and we're
country and different parts of the world
and the success was really great still
having the distribution and so we said
okay let's get a broker maybe yo a
Booker and maybe the Booker can set up
some screenings well how much is it
gonna cost us as we're going into the
costs for the Booker to maybe say 5 or 6
a.m. in these theaters or something man
between the booking and the promotion
and Kenneth we're dry good run but they
film fizzles and so I got a call on the
phone
Oprah Winfrey's interested in you guys
screen the film for her okay
sent it to Scott over there and it's got
looked at it brought it to Oprah's
office saw it and he said what's your
lawyers name and what's that happen is
it was a I'm not gonna lie man I knew it
was a pain it was painful man some days
you want me to say forget it man give up
what about it was painful and what was
the time frame are we talking about a
year and a half I mean you're talking
about you know your your your bank
account is dry and you got bills to pay
and your accountants pissed at you to
the degree of your you really are
something's wrong with you you spent
this money for your mortgage this year
and where is that gonna come from you're
crazier and you start thinking crazy and
then divine intervention it what if you
want to call it says you're you're doing
something that we want you to do so
we're gonna help you and when that
happens it's like first time we take a
deep breath in I need a long time but
you can't give up you just
it's that it's it's this the blessing
and curse of this industry you know you
it's it's a blessing and a curse I mean
you keep going because you're passionate
you're gonna get it done you know but
it's not painless and then when someone
sees what you see and they have
distribution and they say it has value
tears and I don't mean the polite time
Eunice the snotty type you know that
kind of stuff that really just thankful
you